there's this interesting period
of uh
in the 20th century
of lsd use
that many of the people doing research
on psychedelics now kind of have their
roots in that history i mentioned that
i've talked to mcdonald
he is one of those people
and there's this interesting story of a
bunch of creatives that used lsd or
other drugs to help them
what do you make of the idea of somebody
like ken kizi who wrote one flew over
the cuckoo's nest in part under the
influence of lsd
like what do you
make
of the use of psychedelics to uh
maximize the creative potential of the
human mind
is this um
is this a as a crutch or is this
actually um
an effective
tool that we should explore
one person's crutch might be another
bungee cord um
you know
it depends on that mind
yeah
think about paul mccartney i mean we
might not have some of the better
beatles music in the absence of lsd
and what did sir paul say in 1967 when
he was asked about his use of lsd he
said that he recognized the dangers
inherent in it but that um he did it
with a very specific very deliberate
purpose in mind um he wanted to find the
answer to what life is all about
and i'm not sure what sir paul is doing
this week but he's probably not doing
lsd
speaking back to my theory about these
these substances being catalyzers of
spiritual introspection um
you know it came along at a time in
their life when i think they were right
for it especially george harrison um i
highly recommend the martin scorsese
documentary
about uh about george harrison um you
know for for them i think it was exactly
the way we ought to investigate it which
is
well mind expanders this is what
psychedelics do right that which makes
manifest the contents of the mind
in the absence of an experience like
that and it can be in a three-day fast
it can be laying down in a cave
it can be in ritual chanting it can be
in a sundance but in the absence of that
kind of experience at the right time in
your life
it may otherwise be very difficult
to find entrance to that kingdom of
heaven which i do think is here and now
getting right back to the very beginning
if we are actually to participate in
that eternal principle how
and when
you